welcome to the Dean show and I'm here
with Adrienne how you doing Adrienne I'm
doing great how are you
we're at his farm as you can see we got
these nice cows and I want to turn you
guys out to something incredible that
probably I don't know it's been a little
bit over a year and I really got into
this raw milk now there's some
misconceptions around it and most people
are really who drink milk they many
people have become lactose intolerant
you know they have all these allergies
is that from drinking raw milk or
pasteurized milk what's the difference
now many people have no clue can you
help educate us so that's actually how
we ended up in the raw milk to begin
with is my oldest daughter Emily who
owns the cows here with her younger
youngest sister Claire she was diagnosed
as lactose intolerance so as a toddler
we went through ear infections and
constipation and diarrhea and all those
things fevers and and then antibiotics
and so she was diagnosed with either a
milk allergy or lactose intolerance well
a a Mennonite guy that used to share
sheep for me we were talking about it
one day at lunch and he said she's not
allergic to milk
she just needs raw melon now I had never
really heard of such a thing and I grew
up on a farm but I didn't grow up
milking cows and so Oh several months
later he called me and he had a heifer
that was about the cab and so he may be
a deal I couldn't refuse and basically
guilted me into buying this this cow
from her and that's precious that's why
they named it freshest pastures that was
the name of our first heifer and so went
when she caved my wife made sure that
the milk was safe for me to drink first
and then and then she and the kids are
drinking and my daughter Emily can drink
raw milk unpasteurized unhomogenized
milk all day and it doesn't give her any
health problems to the contrary its
health giving to her so there's a lot of
people that have a lot of problems that
you know if conventional pasteurized
homogenized milk is not working well for
them oftentimes raw milk will and it's a
misconception that you know the foods
that we eat don't have any influence on
our our gut bacteria all those sorts of
things you know that that I think you
know I meet a lot of people that raw
milk solves a lot of problems if you
don't mind in time early 1900s they had
two distilleries and it was very filthy
people were getting sick and they
developed this concept now of killing
the bad bacterias and and then it became
a big industry now right and the
difference between then how it started
and and the movement the big raw milk
movement now the difference because like
I was very very scared to you know
nervous I thought I was gonna get sick
or something but can you let's go back
in time to how this whole pasteurization
process started so you need to remember
that as the what they call them brewery
dairies those were dairies that sprang
up around breweries in the middle of
pretty heavily populated areas so they
had all of this brewery waste that they
needed to get rid of her sometimes it's
referred to as distillers and so cows
could eat that and and cows would
produce milk on that but a cows cows you
know hay for the first nine thousand ten
thousand years however long that cows
have been domesticated depending on what
culture you're from
they'd never eaten distilled grains you
know that wasn't something that cows had
ever eaten so they were filthy
conditions the cows were not healthy
they you need to remember then they also
didn't have stainless steel they didn't
have you know full tank refrigeration
they didn't they didn't have
and so all of those things you you can
certainly in in unhygenic conditions
with any sort of a food product you
could certainly have problems but but
those had inherent problems that you
know once you got away from the any
unhealth in the cows then then you
certainly got healthier milk I mean it's
you know so tuberculosis in cows was a
real thing I mean that there there are
diseases that you have to watch out for
in animals and so you can influence that
on the health of the animals but you
could also just through good husbandry
you know in cleanliness and and
carefulness and refrigeration and
stainless steel and all the sort of
things that we have now that they didn't
have then but I was also argue you know
when all of the Midwest
farm farm people went off to fight in
World War 1 now these were some of the
healthiest people on earth you know that
there was a reason you know
why they why they were you know so
inherently healthy he's caused a very
very friendly see they we got look so
tell us how when you go through the
pasteurization process I mean like the
crater has has given us you know this
gift of food and how it was intended I
mean back before a hundred years ago
there was no such thing as
pasteurization was there and there was
no such thing as refrigeration so you
know if you go back if you go back to
the land flowing with milk and honey if
you go back to when they talk about in
ancient writings of people eating curds
and whey you know they they talked about
sitting and eating curds if you came if
you came on to the earth you know nine
thousand years ago any milk that you had
especially in the Mediterranean areas or
you know equate equatorial areas of the
world was was already starting to turn
towards sour so you know you didn't
drink cold milk in those temperate zones
you know so when you ate curdled milk
there that's full of all sorts of
bacterias like we would have in good
bacteria
we would have in yogurts and stuff that
I would argue you know we human humans
have evolved for lack of a better term
at the same rate that as as our
agriculture has and and milk consumption
and all of the you know cream and whey
products and all these all came up at
the same time let's talk a little bit
tell us Adrian what what actually the
process when you pasteurize the built
there's so many I mean we can safely say
that I mean milk is like a superfood you
may get so many nutrients and and the
vitamins and minerals and proteins when
you pasteurized it do you destroy all
that what happens in the process well
you can destroy them or you can make
them way way less digestible you know
that the the easiest milk to digest is
if you're gonna drink milk is actually
warm milk milk that hasn't even been
chilled yet but then you can also
collaborate there are people that
collaborate that never never refrigerate
it so it's kind of going towards kefir
going towards yogurt so it's so but
pasteurizing and homogenizing they're
both you know pretty harsh
processes on a pretty delicate product
so you know all of the good bacteria all
the probiotics all the things that you
know we as mammals and and and the
mammals that we you know milk that it
you know you need all of those available
fats and proteins and all those things
that you know i would argue that the
homogenous asian is really bad for the
fat part and that you get particles that
are small enough to cause all sorts of
gut problems they know the I it's my
opinion that you know these
diverticulitis problems that Crohn's
problems and all these are at least
exer baited by pasteurized homogenized
milk but but also all the other things
in our diet that are you know processed
to take the the goodness that you know
nine or ten thousand years a human
evolution you know gut bacteria is all
those sorts of things that that we're
missing out on so all of a sudden we're
having to add probiotics back into our
diet or we're on antibiotics all the
time and you know I would argue the same
thing would would take place in you know
other young mammal
that you know if they work if they
didn't have access to two raw milk as
well so isn't there enzymes also and I
milk that help us digest it so you know
if you take the my test for people would
be to fight get to find yourself some
raw milk put it in a glass on a counter
put it put a paper towel over it but
don't seal it so that it goes anaerobic
and take conventional pasteurized
homogenized milk set it next to the
thing the same way your raw milk in
several days will clabber but you could
you could mix it back up and I've done
this you know in two weeks to
unrefrigerated and it'll curd and you it
still tasty and digestible your your
pasteurized homogenized milk will rock
little putrefy because it the enzymes
that are in there that are good in there
all along there they were the put there
in the beginning to make you know a milk
a movable thing that we could take with
us you know nine thousand years ago
before refrigeration and before you know
if you think about it pasteurization was
available nine thousand years ago right
you could have heated milk it could have
been done but they didn't do it because
you didn't have a melt a system where
you had to have milk that would last for
days or weeks or months you know and you
you ate as fresher food as you could and
that's that's how now now let me talk
about another point if you take some of
these cows that don't see the light of
day they're they're being fed foods that
they're not made to eat you know corn
and grains and and then they get it sick
and they got a pump on my antibiotics
and if you drink that milk that built
needs to be pasteurized right that'll
get you sick if you drink it but I mean
the way that God Almighty intended for
these animals that are human that are
humanely treated that are that are out
you know eating what God intended them
for to eat in a good clean environment
like you have here I mean that
the kind of the milk that's safe oh
absolutely can you talk about the
difference Oh certainly that there are
there are so cows that are milked
specifically dairy cow they don't many
own don't see the light of day right and
they never have grass and they don't eat
much forage so so a cow if you watch
these cows if they're not eating or
resting or in this case they're kind of
excited to see people but when they're
ruminating that they're adjusting their
body pH so a cow with it a good sized
cow will have like a 50 gallon rumen so
that's meant to have roughage did the
whole idea is they've got a four
chambered stomach there Reuben it and so
that that actually buffers their system
so the cow like that is is has so much
good bacteria on them that the bad
bacteria can never get a foothold and
really take over but but a cow so we've
we've taken cattle and everybody's heard
of mad cow disease and that sort of
thing well those are functions of what
we feed cows so you know cows are cows
or herbivores in general would never eat
each other
right there's omnivores there there are
you know we're omnivores but they're you
know there are there are animals that we
eat that are omnivores that would eat
other beef cows won't do that but but we
forced them into that situation because
of cheap nutrition so when they rendered
dead animals and feed them you know it
whether it's the cattle or sheep or that
sort of thing you know you're creating a
situation that's unnatural has never
occurred you know in ten thousand years
of Agriculture and
it's definitely probably spoke you know
never meant to happen misconceptions
about Islam number two Muslim women are
oppressed one of the most disturbing
misconceptions is the negative portrayal
of women in Islam namely that Islam
degrades and oppresses women this
misconception is due to the negative
culture and traditions that people all
over the world still hold on to
unfortunately these traditions sometimes
overshadow the Islamic teaching and
people from the outside believe that the
traditions and Islam are the same when
in reality they are not for example
women in pre-islamic Arabia had almost
no rights they reviewed as objects and
were constantly humiliated their purpose
was nothing more than to obey men and
have children for him when a female baby
was born it was considered a disgrace to
the family and they were often buried
alive Islam brought positive change to
Arabia people who embraced Islam had to
let go of these harmful cultural
practices and woman were finally given
the rights and respect that they
deserved for every male convert to Islam
today for females convert to the
religion
nobody will convert to religion that
oppresses them the truth is the Islam
provides women with the rights they
deserve to be successful in this world
and the next number 1 Muslims are
terrorists and extremists this is by far
the biggest misconception of Islam given
unfairly by stereotyping and the public
image that immediate us has anyone else
noticed how when a specific group of
people attack another group of people it
is labeled as a hate crime but when a
Muslim opens fire on anybody is quickly
regarded as terrorism many political
dictators and officials or extremist
groups use the name of Islam as a
strategy to gain followers and attention
when many of their practices go against
the teachings of Islam Islam does not
support terrorism under any
circumstances terrorism goes against
every principle in Islam and if a Muslim
engages in terrorism he is not following
Islam
Islam prohibits Muslims from attacking
or killing any innocent person Allah
says whoever kills a person in justly it
is as though he has killed all mankind
on chapter 5 verse 32 one more thing
big business I mean after everything the
whole process got started we see that
you know this is actually you know bad
for business that the raw movement
starts to grow but it is growing people
are waking and seeing that this is not
how the Creator intended it for it to be
pasteurized and you kill all the good
stuff in there the raw milk the way that
it was for us that's the way we want it
and there's a movement now right well I
hope there's a movement it's it's my
argument has been and I've talked to
every every politician I could find in
the state of Illinois and all the Health
Department feel like it's fine but you
know the trouble with it with a issue
like raw milk is your small farmers and
your only essentially dealing with
people who really seek out their own
food so who take that responsibility the
difficulty on this issue in Illinois has
been we have a two-party system in our
in our government and one party loves
big business and the other party loves
big government and neither of them love
individuals you know supplying a public
with something that they want but you
know without a good without an
in-between like I meet the most
fascinating people the best educated
people the most self-aware people that
you'd ever meet selling raw milk it's
been an it's been an epiphany for me
that that you know and the difficulty is
that you know people that are the most
passionate about what they eat and what
they put in their body have the most
trouble
getting getting I the government to
acquiesce to let them do that
and that's that's a really that's a big
frustration for me it's a huge I mean
I'm a fifth-generation Illinois farmer
and you know my daughters would love to
keep their cows and continue to do this
but you know it's it's kind of a race to
see you know who who wins out I guess
here with Adrienne
tell us if people want to visit you your
daughter's website how can they are they
could they come out and see you here at
the farm
so unfortunately according to my wife
worked and we milk cows twice a day
every day so that farm is at three eight
seven South Malta Road and Rochelle
Illinois I would ask you to call ahead
and then also visit my daughter's
website it's precious pastures calm
precious again was the old original cow
and she was just a pearl of an animal
just a joy to have around so thank you
thank you sir thank you very much
subscribe right now